It’s Thank You Thursday
and I believe that every entrepreneur
needs to take time out to recognize the people
in their life who are having a big impact
or helping them; give them encouragement
give them ideas, give them advice.
And so today’s Thank You Thursday
is Nina and Nina’s been a big part of my life
and has always been a huge supporter
of everything that I do.
And I come up with some crazy ideas
and I want to try some crazy things
and a lot of things don’t work out
but win, lose or fail I always have Nina’s support
and she always has my back.
She believes.
And I’m willing to try a whole bunch of stuff
and willing to fail at it
and a lot of people are so afraid of failing
that they’re not even willing to try.
And you have to be willing to go through that failure
and hopefully you have people behind you
who support you and have your back.
So one quick story;
I got a lot for Nina but one quick story.
I launched a new campaign under Patreon
which you’ll see in the link of all my videos
now on the description
and it’s basically asking people to support me.
It’s, you know, if you like the videos
you understand that I make these videos for free
I have costs and time and a team that I support
and I do it to answer your questions
and to motivate and inspire you
and so I ask for support, for help.
And it’s basically a monthly subscription.
You’re paying as little as $1 a month
or whatever amount you want.
So I launched the campaign.
I didn’t know if it would work, right
try a bunch of stuff, see what works.
I’d be willing to fail.
And the next day I woke up and I had my first supporter
and it was Nina. Surprise, surprise, right.
She always believes in what I’m doing
and I’m forever grateful to have somebody
like that in my life who always has my back
and always believes.
So thank you Nina.
I love you.
For those of you who are watching
I encourage you to take time today
on Thank You Thursday to find someone in your life
who is helping you, right
is giving you ideas, is giving you feedback
is giving you motivation, inspiration and saying
“Hey, you can do it” because as entrepreneurs
we can’t do it alone.
So take the time out, say thank you.
Believe.
For those of you watching, you liked the video
you can support me, click on the link in the description.
Leave a comment. Let me know what you think.
And click on my face to subscribe to the channel.
Thank you so much, I’ll see you soon.